if you know horror then you're likely
very familiar with James Juan in the
various Works he's had a hand in over
the years his first mainstream hit came
in 2004 in the form of Saul which set
him on a prosperous yet spooky Hollywood
path in the years that followed Juan
directed such Productions as dead
silence and Insidious before he really
found his Groove in 2013. his
supernatural horror flaked The Conjuring
premiered that year launching him into
the entertainment Stratosphere and
kick-starting a highly successful
cinematic franchise that moviegoers
can't get enough of whether you adore
The Conjuring universe or don't Harbor
much love for it it's impossible to deny
its place among the most popular horror
franchises out there from the nun to
Annabelle that has grown exponentially
throughout the 2010s thanks in large
part to positive fan feedback therefore
it only makes sense that it will
continue to expand into the 2020s and
likely Beyond one such addition that has
been in limbo for a while is the Crooked
Man spin-off title focused on the
terrifying character from The Conjuring
2 that was first discussed back in 2017.
[Music]
foreign
ly for those hoping to see the crooked
man at the movies we have some bad news
the long gestating offshoot film is no
longer happening as revealed by James
Wan himself on November 4th 2022 James
Wan made an Instagram post containing
several behind the scenes photos of his
ghoulish friend the Crooked Man or
rather Javier botet since he's the
person who brought the horrifying entity
to life in The Conjuring 2. after
reminding the world that his unsettling
movements were possible using age-old
camera tricks and not CGI Juan gave a
discouraging update on the Crooked Man
Centric spin-off much to the dismay of
all who wanted to see the film happen he
wrote unfortunately the spin-off movie
with this character isn't happening but
maybe one day at the time of this video
it's unknown why exactly the Crooked Man
spin-off isn't happening although it
stands to reason that James wands
already packed schedule didn't help the
matter easily his most time consuming
effort heading into 2023 is Aquaman and
the lost kingdom which he's directing
and producing at the same time he is
also helping out with the likes of Megan
Insidious 5 Mortal Kombat 2 and other
projects in various roles that's a lot
for any any one person to handle so it
would make sense that this workload may
have caused a crooked man to slip by the
wayside thankfully if you're upset that
the crooked man isn't happening and
you're hoping to return to The Conjuring
Universe sometime soon more films are on
the way next up on the dockets is the
sequel to 2018's The none which will
debut on September 8th 2023. Michael
Chavez of the curse of the La Llorona
and The Conjuring the devil made me do
at Fame will sit in the director's chair
with Bonnie Ahrens reprising her valik
role opposite taisa Farmiga as Sister
Irene after the non-sequel terrifies
moviegoers The Conjuring 4 will arrive
carrying on the story of Ed Lorraine
Warren beyond the devil made me do it as
of this video the sequel lacks a release
date and a director but it stands to
reason that it'll reach the Silver
Screen sooner rather than later don't be
surprised if we're ordered more entries
into the franchise come to light down
the line as well
too bad that for the time being the
Crooked Man won't get a spotlight of his
own in the form of a proper spin-off
movie at least fans can look forward to
Other Stories within the conjuring
universe as well as other James Juan
efforts as consolation prizes
[Music]